hi I'm Patrick I'm Nicole
[Music]
listen I'm gonna say this bro hello
how's it going hi I'm Drew I'm Julia
whoa what happened
what
say it sometimes you just see someone
like
I think she likes them dark just the way
that she's Oh yay hey hold up hold up
hold up when you look about 32 and you
wearing leopard
and the way she said that nice
so just pay attention how she walked in
no no no no no no hold on hold on hold
on
yay
I just I don't know if he if he rocking
with with Dave hello how's it going hi
I'm Drew she didn't want to move the
chairs PB game the mental thing watch
watch watch watch she swooped like that
because she don't want to make the noise
with the chair because the chair are
gonna make a fart noise and she don't
want to be associated with that you know
I mean I never think about [ __ ] like
that I know it was all that physics to
me it was just the way she said in
sideways and she said she swooped in but
this show she went how's it going
I already told you guys once the head
tilts start coming in like this let me
do that women only do that extra bit of
head movement if they into you because
if a woman not she's gonna stare at your
dead pants but is she doing all this
extra [ __ ] huh you know
it's going well
five bucks he's gonna hit the button
again and Julia you have a great smile
thanks I appreciate that did you kill
that leopard did you
um don't call me a poacher but I might
[Music]
I don't care what nobody [ __ ] says
you guys saw the body language if y'all
thought I was bullshitting before you
better not be thinking now you may not
be thinking now the way she going honey
stupid
Tyler Creator once said don't trust a
woman a fake leopard okay well this is
going really well yeah
I told you he wasn't feeling it oh look
at look at her face like whatever no
it's like okay sorry
I like you really said see you on bumble
hey yo shout out to this woman I
actually like her I like her I like her
do your thing girlfriend hey that's my
time
why did you reject her I didn't like her
outfit
how are you I'm okay uh I'm okay
I'm not malfunctioning if I'm okay hun
okay the only time you should be making
noise like that is when you got a dick
in your mouth let me just say that you
just go
that's a lot what nothing what'd I say I
don't know no you you you looked at me
like sus that's what you're fine no not
all you don't think I saw your little
hell tilt you don't think I don't know
what you [ __ ] thinking before you
said it no I know when you were
suspicious you're fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right go ahead give him
the look do it what look see go ahead
don't I know because you're gonna wait
till I start talking to you I don't know
what you're talking about you see the
way his hand moved he's upset I
predicted what he was getting no not at
all so he literally changed it not at
all not at all I'm not upset at all
alcohol
I saw you do it too
[ __ ] you act like I don't edit these
videos okay I
I'm gonna do the zooming I know all the
things that you're gonna make are we
doing internet or not are we getting
paid or not it's called material
goddamn bro are you good I'm good
I like your top that's a that's a nice
flannel okay well tell me about yourself
what makes you so good
you definitely gonna hit that button
she's going but then she's definitely
playing and the thing the thing is that
she's seen [ __ ] buzzing and
she's like okay this [ __ ]
buzzing [ __ ] too quick so you
think so you think you're that hot all
right so what makes you think that good
that's that's the undertone I want to
give a shout out to Metal Gear Solid you
know I mean that should tell me about
spies tell me about deception and I know
when someone's in Disguise not so much
that I'm so good I just like everybody
should know what they like and I feel
like we shouldn't waste each other's
time okay so what do you not like about
me
um that's a very hard question what do
you not like about me at first glance
what are you like oh glance only glance
only she said oh I had a lot of [ __ ] to
say about your personality but let's
talk about your fit
what the heck is that it's cool um it's
affordable
sorry
why did you reject him I didn't like his
eyes attitude
what's your name uh my name is Taylor
what's your name they put the [ __ ]
fur again
I'm Nicole hi Nicole so what kind of
hobbies gonna do I have an aquarium a 55
gallon aquarium what you gotta actually
get into the mindset of afraid to
understand first all right I'm good are
you sure I don't want to go in the
mindset of a fury but listen weren't you
all about that empathy empathy
except for human beings
furries are people too no they're not
they're just people in costumes
show some love to our fellow for first
hey to all the furry fans how do you
unsubscribe
that's a good little doggy now be sure
to like comment and subscribe
if you love The Furies I'm not gonna lie
if I saw a furry online if I'm swiping
it's a girl furry and she's like uh you
know
I'd swipe just for the experience yeah
yeah I just want a [ __ ] book a a
reservation at a nice restaurant tell
the [ __ ] to come in and find her
costume yeah yeah sit down and just
confuse the waiter and try to meet why
are you taking your hat off because I
gotta eat yeah oh no [ __ ] you about
this life yeah yeah and when we go to
pay uh I get I tip in doggie treats
something weird like that you know just
to get a little spicy with it
so glad and I put a put a leash on the
[ __ ] and leave
uh excuse me sir you can't do that to a
person that's my [ __ ] what you gonna do
about it keep going
that's not like a beautiful experience
are you not gonna address the elephant
in the room what elephant in the room
I am a furry
what is a parade the way that I just
grab it is mental health
that I would describe it Mental Health
[ __ ] mental health as extreme deep [ __ ]
listen no no no no no no no no no no no
no no do not put [ __ ] otakus and them
[ __ ] in the same Buddhism no it's not
same thing not the same thing same thing
go ahead for those dressing different
things what I said what I said go ahead
[ __ ] dressing you wanna know
where the difference is go ahead we
don't [ __ ] those things
that that's a that's a lie what a lot of
money that's a lot what that's you don't
[ __ ] those things what do you mean
the [ __ ] life no no no no no no you
think [ __ ] out here putting on
Naruto I've seen your [ __ ] Sailor
Moon outfit in that I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding I just gotta just because
no no now you just started conspiracies
[ __ ] think I'm like tuxedo mass by day
tuxedo black listen no no it's not the
same you know takus let preach know you
feel disrespected no no no no no no for
being convinced you a [ __ ] furry they
they [ __ ] you someone you know you you
know who y'all are you're [ __ ] there
all right stop is it a sex thing it is
definitely not just a sex thing
it's not have you had sex wearing that
oh great
hi I'm Patrick I'm Nicole nice to meet
you
laughs
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh I see people
oh my God
Patrick eh if you are going to go to a
foreign country learn the art of
deception oh my God you are God you you
cannot sit there and let them know what
you are thinking it is written all over
your face like you have taken a pencil
and you have decided to write I wish to
press the button don't do it what were
you thinking what was he thinking I'm
going to press the button no that's what
I thought
she's really white
when I've come here from Africa when
they said there are white people and I
did not know they meant like snow like
ghosts like a cocaine
this one this one is white this one is
transparent so you're on a date
Patrick
yeah she was about my dad hi I'm Patrick
Patrick yeah okay I'm Jade dude I have a
question
um are you the type of person to tell
someone when they have something in
their teeth
Hey listen Patrick you can't just
constantly
my man if you put water in his mouth it
would just yeah it would just
dribble are you the type of person to
tell someone when they have something in
their teeth
[Music]
um
yes yeah you have something on my teeth
thank you yeah
Jay why did you reject him I think he
was very soft-spoken I'm Jade I'm Jane
I'm Joel Jade with a d Jade with a d e
so tell me about yourself about me um I
really like to dance
ouch
Mental Health
[Music]
the laugh he's soft-spoken
she laughs like me
he looked to one of us and they said why
people can't dance
well black people can't laugh
nice meeting you
this dance moves just weren't it for me
my name is Joel what's your name Izzy
Izzy I love your shirt like what's it
what's the inspiration behind it I
thrifted it and it was cute
listen I'm not gonna say nothing about
people who look like they came from a
thrift shop man my man looks like he
shops at Walmart they don't seem
compatible whatsoever I love thrift
shops right like which one's your
favorite
um there's one in uh
it's green
I forgot yeah Joel is a good Christian
boy you're a good Christian boy
why did you reject him he's a good
Christian boy is that a problem
absolutely
Maven is he what's your sign
I'm a cap porn God damn it where's the
button nope nope there's something about
I like that's all that happens for me
ever I'm grounded that's all I know yeah
that's what you guys all say
get the [ __ ] out of here so you found
out he was a Capricorn and went yeah no
oh listen this is why I don't like
Communists man
they just be out here saying the dumbest
[ __ ] bro bro why can't we just
redistribute chlamydia like what's the
problem
when it comes to people no no no no no
no I'm being honest bro there's just
something about people who who shop at
thrift shop that you just look at them
you're like listen I can imagine
pronouns definitely in your Twitter bio
I'm saying armpits unshaven coochie
untested there's just something about
that look let's go yeah I think you're
cute hey for sure and I say Q because
like I feel like uh beautiful would be
kind of cliche so I feel like as a whole
like you're very aesthetically pleasing
to me all right [ __ ] boy all right [ __ ]
boy you know I feel like just the
compliment of the word beautiful is just
so overrated and overused but I think Q
really describes your entire being your
entire Persona just the way that you
walked in sauntered it I know I walked
in so I didn't actually see you walked
in but I can imagine that you probably
just came in here very casual
non-presumptive humble you probably come
from a good family you know what I mean
good supportive people I could see your
values rating through your pores me
personally
I'm just in between relationships you
know like uh I went from the previous
battery relationship and I'm looking
forward to meeting my future wife so at
this point I'm just
seeing what's out there and trying to
find the right one for me so we can
spend the rest of our lives together uh
but no pressure I'd just like for us to
get to know each other sit down have
some coffee maybe we can get to know
each other you know I mean my friends
can meet your friends and then maybe we
can do this every evening you know shout
out Biggie Smalls
who's Biggie Smalls that's my pastor
good man died last year
what was that
sorry what
do I want to use a condom why would I
[ __ ] boys
how many times have guys been by the
magazine she went where's the condom you
went wait what
um
once you're in a relationship are you
like an open relationship are you like
committee like what is this oh if I were
to be in a relationship I would want to
just be monogamous okay go same
he said same but in the way he said he
went like the only time you ask somebody
if they want to be monogamous or open as
a man it's because you want to be open
yeah and he looks like somebody who
wants to be open that's my suspicion
yeah because I don't know just most of
the time it's women who are asking that
because women get off to the ass to be
in open relationships or like the man
wants to [ __ ] around are you a jealous
person I'm not really jealous person no
I'm not either I feel like I provide
enough for them to be comfortable if
there's somebody that I should be
worried about then
boy's favorite word
where are we like what are we now you
know we're vibing
been [ __ ] for three months and I met
your Mom and Dad we're vibing and you
got to fight with my mom and dad let's
Vibe some more
listen Ladies as soon as the guy starts
talking about Vibes and says it more
than five times Run for the hills dudes
if you want to be a [ __ ] boy stop using
that word they starting to sniff that
[ __ ] out
did you go to college yeah I'm still in
school right now how old are you 21. I
turned 22 on Wednesday baby how old are
you Andrea's age preference is 21 to 35.
damn snitching yeah I went through a lot
as a kid so like I think maturity is
based off experience not age uh that's
the exact same thing that Weinstein's
well you would like to go on a second
date I'd be down yeah congratulations
and you won yourself a date with a [ __ ]
boy now enjoy yourselves at The Vibes
hey but anyways let us know what you
guys think uh you know some of you are
wondering yo I do give people advice on
like what to look out for in a football
and then also tell the [ __ ] boys what
not to do so they don't get caught uh
because I just like making money
I play both sides do you feel me it's
kind of like an arms dealer in the
middle of the war you'll sell weapons to
whoever because you don't really give a
[ __ ] as long as you get to settle that's
what I'm doing
wet puns wet puns for sale